directing for Nebraska hello good
morning hello thank you thank you thank
you really hard to we talk about
Nebraska a lot of films and then lot
more class that was more possible over
after
not better than Bruce but they readily
came to mind right Henry Fonda and
Walter Brennan Percy Kilbride Warren
Oates if he had lived he would have been
good for the part but not as good as
Bruce I have to say that but I mean it
yeah thnkx face things did I answer
that's official ok story knock you back
here for KBC oh hi there I love seeing
all these faces I've never seen before
give one or two lines sitting in a bar
going up to Bruce it a bus stop where
did these people come from and noble
Circuit was it thanks for asking
possibly fully half of the speaking
parts in the film or from non-actors
people from rural Nebraska and Iowa and
us is it difficult it's not difficult
it's like law school it's not difficult
it's just time consuming so it took
about a year of casting and putting out
the word on rural radio and in
small-town newspapers and getting the
word out especially to get the retired
farmers but for example the guy you
asked about who comes up to him at the
bus stop he's never been an actor before
he answered a notice in the Des Moines
Register he's from Des Moines Iowa and
we fitted in his scenes between kidney
dialysis he's been on dialysis every
other day for almost 40 years so
everybody's got his story but we made it
work cuz that guy is so good he's like
from a preston sturges movie that guy no
one just get it started
hi Susan sweet of you to say thank you
inspiration uh that's always a hard
answer a hard question to answer I just
like the screenplay I didn't write the
script it's the first one I've directed
that I didn't write and I just like the
the deadpan humor and the sadness
underneath and the austerity and and
that it was about kindness I like it
when movies are about kindness by the
way I just saw the oscar-nominated short
documentaries yesterday and they are
fantastic and I recommend watching the
oscar-nominated short documentaries yeah
that's it no concrete film I think
inspired it necessarily and I was
inspired maybe a little bit to buy my
own relationship with my own aging
parents a lot of us are going through
that right now good alright thanks so
much for your interest